hello everybody time again for another
movie retrospective this year was a
movie that if you remember a couple
months ago was was now probably well we
went to fy8 tales want mall and I bought
a lot of cheap ass flicks yeah two or
three dollars each and I think I posted
a picture on patreon like of all the
ones I had and I said I will probably
get around to reviewing maybe not all of
them but some of them and this was one
of the ones that I got so this is the
one of the ones that we are reviewing
this is 28 days later from 2002 yeah
what time went by dinner it did indeed
sorry is that old now now the
interesting thing about 28 days later
not only is this an awesome I'm gonna
call it a quasi zombie flick because I
don't want people yelling at me those
zombie flicks aren't zombies well get
into that in a minute but this was also
um a very important Dombey flick for the
horror genre because you have to
consider that before 2002 I mean the
heyday for zombie movies was kind of
like 70s to 80s you know you got you
know George Romero's stuff you got like
Return of the Living Dead you got like
reanimate er you got all that kind of on
me yeah like all the italian flicks that
came out um you know living dead in
manchester morgue all that kind of stuff
coming out in the 80s
after that not so much there was um
there was a few every now and then like
cemetery man that came out in the 90s
that was also Italian Dead Alive the
Peter Jackson that was Australian New
Zealand whatever it was but awesome what
probably have to review that at some
point too because I [ __ ] love that
movie I think finished zombie you've
seen it you can't say I've seen it many
times I got maybe 1/3 way through it for
some reason we never finished it I don't
remember what happened to drunk yeah
paying attention something something
else I don't know
never seen never did see the zombie okay
well we'll watch it one of these days I
think it's still unshut or somewhere but
um yeah so this one so like I said Somme
B's had kind of like fallen out of
fashion I guess like as a horror
sub-genre even there though even though
there were like a few examples every now
and then but when 28 days later came out
it's sort of like reinvigorated the end
zombie genre pretty much all the zombie
[ __ ] that you have now like all the
zombie movies you know that came after
that like obviously Walking Dead the War
Z World War Z like all the books that
came out like warm bodies the stuff like
that we're pretty much come from this
movie and the Resident Evil games I mean
that's those are the two things this is
where it all comes from this brought
brought the idea that or at least kind
of popularized the idea of the fast
zombie as far as I know this was the
first one to do that yeah I didn't like
it when I first saw it yeah a while you
get used to it
well like I said technically they're not
zombies because they're not dead people
return their life they're human beings
that have been infected with a virus
range by rage now something that's
interesting to me and I've seen this I
saw this mentioned in one review but
probably not in a bunch of other ones
clearly this is a lot to you know the
George Romero zombie movies just kind of
been tone and structure but I think it's
actually more similar to another movie
that he did more of an outbreak
post-apocalyptic type of movie that he
did in 1973 called two crazies that was
actually a movie about people that were
infected with a virus called trixie that
was like a bio weapon that had gotten
released into the water and it made
everybody either killed you or turned
you into like a homicidal maniac you
know I mean so I I don't see this movie
like when people talk about this movie
they don't really mention the crazy so
much except for one that I saw but I was
like to me it seems more like an
outbreak movie than a zombie movie and
Danny Boyle who directed it I mean he's
kind of gone on he said well I don't
really consider it a zombie mood I
considered it more like a
post-apocalyptic type of movie which it
is but it has you know parallels to the
zombie genre and it usually gets lumped
in with zombie movies so you know and
honestly like I said after this came out
with the fast zombies since everybody
dug that so much because a lot of people
thought it made them scarier because
they're not just like shambling after
you and it's like oh I'm gonna get you I
could just run back over to us in a
thing of opinion right there yeah and
well I think they're both scary in their
own way yeah there's to me ever since I
was a kid when I first stumbled across
Night of the Living Dead plain
for free on television okay in
California the whole idea of just a mass
of slow-moving people you can run but
you can't ever really get away from
because there's so many there's so and
they keep coming yeah and you can rot
into a house for safety but guess what
they just keep coming
yeah and then they just keep coming and
then instead of 20 you got 200 and then
you got 2,000 then you got 20,000 they'd
knock the whole house down yeah so
there's something about that slow-motion
impending doom something that you can
run from but never truly escape look to
me that reminded me of nightmares I had
as a kid trying to run for something it
feels like you're running in molasses
yeah yeah yeah you know I mean in there
that's what it felt like and like I was
gonna say I think that's what a lot of
people found so scary about like say
Jason Voorhees here just kind of like
mosey to after you but like kind of
caught up with you anyway also a movie
like it follows you know which was kind
of a recent movie where you just where
this thing was just like coming after
you it like kind of just a normal pace
but it was gonna get you like there was
an inevitability to it find that you
bring up you brought up Jason because we
just revisited Friday the 13th part one
two and three and I grew up with them I
loved them as I was you know as a kid
you know young teenager you know but you
look at those movies now sure there
wasn't a whole hell of a lot to those
movies no there was especially three
three was very flimsy yeah yeah the
second one I kind of think is the best
one is I agree with you I mean I don't
like the first one but I'm gonna give
the edge to this I like the characters
in the second one better just this first
to really I think out of the whole
series I just got more ridiculous as it
went on well yes in space and [ __ ] well
yeah the other ones were yeah stupid
just fighting to yeah yeah so like I
said this movie was directed by Danny
Boyle
he had previously done you know a few
other he's most famous now probably for
Trainspotting he also did a slum
millionaire which you know it's got huge
accolades I'm gonna recommend and a lot
of people haven't seen this one this one
of his early flicks and I can't read
what year it came out but it was called
shallow grave it had Ewan McGregor in it
I think Christopher Eccleston was in it
also and he was in 28 days later - it's
an awesome movie and I think a lot of
people haven't seen it even people that
are like kind of like Tim Danny Boyle's
other flicks it's kind of like it's not
a horror movie necessarily it's kind of
like a thriller but it has like a lot
it's kind of gory and violent but I
would recommend that say if you won't
watch it now another thing that this
movie did like I said other than
introducing the concept of quote/unquote
fast zombies or at least people that had
they're almost like mental like [ __ ]
tweakers man they're just like common
and they actually to play the infected
people they just call them the infected
in the movie they actually recruited
like a bunch of athletes because they
wanted this kind of propulsive thing
where it's like you couldn't get away
from them because they were just like
running like full pelt like after you
and like that there was no way that you
could get away from them so it concerns
the main character who's played by
Killian Murphy who actually got you know
is very famous nowadays but this was
kind of one of his early films he'd only
been a couple of indie films before this
one and he plays the character of Jim
now prior to him like he was a bicycle
courier and he got hit by a car and he
was in a coma so he's in the hospital in
a coma
now before we find out about that we see
a little prologue and there's like a
government lab I think it's in Cambridge
in England and they're studying
chimpanzees there study studying like
violent tendencies and these chimps have
become infected with this virus called a
rage virus now these animal liberation
activists like break into the lab and
they're going to release the chimps now
the doctors tell them please don't do
that they're infected with the rage
virus is gonna be really bad but they do
it anyway and chaos inevitably ensues so
by the time Jim wakes up from his coma
pretty much the entirety of Britain has
been decimated either everyone is dead
or it or they've become infected
now astute listeners will note that the
Walking Dead started pretty much in
exactly the same
the gringo familiar waking up in the
hospital now I'm gonna say like cuz I
thought that the Walking Dead graphic
novel series I thought that started in
2003 which was a year after this movie
came out so I'm not saying that
Kirkman like ripped this idea off
because it's possible here's a thing
from a storytelling point of view if
you're gonna tell like a
post-apocalyptic story like a zombie
apocalypse apocalypse or whatever it's
like from a storytelling standpoint it's
good to have your main character your
protagonist not be there like for the
first part of the outbreak so you don't
have to have like all this build up and
set up and everything like that because
they can wake up and not know what's
going on and then you can kind of
quickly catch them up on what's going on
because other people have been
experiencing it the whole time and you
can kind of like cut down on exposition
and all that other kind of [ __ ] you know
I mean you don't have to show this big
like buildup of society falling apart
like once the guy wakes up society's
already falling apart and he just has to
have like a five minute scene with
somebody tell him hey this happened that
happened you're [ __ ] you know I mean
and which is essentially what happens in
this now what a lot of people point out
and this is really actually one of the
best shots in the movie is that when Jim
wakes up and he's in the hospital all by
himself and he was some of the [ __ ] is
going on he leaves the hospital and goes
into the streets of London and they are
completely abandoned now I first saw
this in the theater and it's shot on
digital video they wanted to shoot it
and this was actually one of the very
few films to do this at the time and
this was only 2002 so a lot of the you
know commercially or you know
consumer-grade digital cameras were not
that great so the look of this is very
like lo-fi you know what I mean it still
looks like shitty handheld camera like a
VHS pretty much nowadays now that was
what he wanted it to look like
specifically he wanted like this kind of
immediacy or like a documentary sort of
look so he deliberately just used these
handheld cameras that you could just buy
off-the-shelf or whatever but what they
did so I saw this in the theater first
and when they did these like creepy
shots of him just like walking around in
his little hospital closed with a little
hoo this [ __ ] in a little plastic bag
and it's just like there's like
Westminster Abbey and there's like Big
Ben and there's like nobody it's just
like [ __ ] just garbage blowing around
in the street and stuff and I'm sitting
there going how the [ __ ] did they film
that I'm like that is amazing I'm like
it didn't look like CGI it didn't look
like anything matte matte paint it was
not what they did those are actually the
streets of London and they are actually
empty what they did was they usually
filmed a lot of times they they filmed
without permits but they actually did
get permits for this particular thing
they said what we did was that we would
go at like right before dawn on Sunday
morning when no one's around and then
they would just block off sections of
streets and just tell everybody to get
out and then they would just film really
quick and then they would just make
another spot it's like the one part
where there's one part where there's
like a double-decker bus that's like
tipped over like in the middle of this
empty street they're like they put the
bus there filmed the scene and then move
the bus away again in like 20 minutes
like so they just kind of had this crew
they were doing like this guerilla
filmmaking type [ __ ] so it's but it
still looks amazing to this day and it's
like super super creepy and I like that
the beginning of the film is like kind
of just this slow creepy like emptiness
and then it just descends into this like
frenetic like fast edited madness with
just like all these red-eyed people like
chasing you and like this Fork and
chaotic like it's filming so you know so
jim has no idea what's going on because
nobody's around he's just like yelling
for help and everything and then all
these people like start running he goes
into this church and there's like all
these dead bodies and he has no idea and
there's another really creepy scene
where you know among all these dead
bodies he's like hello hello is anybody
in here and then this one guy pops up
and like looks at him like that and
another guy pops up it looks at her he's
like oh [ __ ] like he starts [ __ ]
running now he eventually gets saved by
two other survivors Selina and Mark now
Selina is played by Naomi Harris who
later went on to play Moneypenny in the
new James Bond yeah so that's the same
actress I think this was her first might
have been her first film role or at
least her first major film role so then
so they kind of explained to him
little bit what's going on they
eventually team up with this other like
kind of a dad figure he's played by
brendan gleeson very famous Irish
character actor he's really good in
everything
and he's him and his daughter of like
barricaded themselves like up in this
big tower block in their apartment so
they've survived and he's like well I
keep hearing these military you know
radio transmissions and they said they
have the cure the infection or the
answer to it or whatever and we have
safety we have beds and food and
everything so come find us were in
Manchester so that's what they do so
like they just kind of get together in
this dad's taxi and they head for
Manchester now in the third act you kind
of get to this military installation
which is there there in like this
mansion and it's fortified and they have
it all set up and all this other kind of
[ __ ] but it turns out that the head of
the little military it's only like a
couple of guys like five guys or
something like that who is played by a
Christopher Eccleston who I love and
pretty much everything he's kind of like
well here's the thing I just put that
radio thing out there because I promised
my men that I would make women come here
so we were just trying to lure women
here so we could quote-unquote
repopulate the earth so so Selena and
the fourteen-year-old girl are basically
going to become sex slaves so Jim the
main character does not what does not
want any part of that so he has to
become sort of like this [ __ ] he has to
become sort of like a rage you know guy
himself just to like kill all these
soldiers and get his you know get the
woman and the daughter like away from
there because this they've almost kind
of become an ersatz family like in the
in the course of the thing now one of
the coolest things about this movie like
I said too is that you know like on The
Walking Dead and stuff it's like if
somebody gets bit you know by a zombie
and then like you have a while like say
goodbye to the person and everyone's
gonna cry about it and everything like
that now the thing that's kind of
horrifying about 28 days later is that
the virus if you don't even have you
don't you have to get bit you can just
get like a drop of the infected person's
blood like in your mouth or in your eye
or they can like spit on you like
or spit in your mouth or something and
you will get it has like a five-second
incubation period you will get it
immediately if that makes more sense
anyway
yeah because the problem with zombie
infections as they're shown in the
Walking Dead is that there wouldn't be
any zombies around because the person
would be eaten yeah and the infected
person is eaten yeah well where are
these zombies coming from if zombies eat
the infected then how do they yeah you
can definitely everyone just get eaten
well in this one and also World War Z
it's a the process is shown very quickly
they'll attack a person and then that
person turns instantly infinitely and
then they'll run it off and they're all
in a pack and they're acting and then
the zombies don't don't bother that
person anymore yeah you know they gained
a member so it makes more sense to have
it like that
that is just an infection you know and
you can see how scary that would be
because essentially and I saw a review
that pointed this out it's like
essentially you'd have like one person
that had it they would almost they would
be like a suicide bomber like you could
put them in a crowd of people and
immediately like the whole crowd would
be infected so it's like you could
easily see how like an whole a whole
island nation such as Great Britain
would be pretty much just devastated in
only a few weeks time because pretty
much everybody would get you would get
eaten I mean there there's not much you
could do and like I said they don't
really eat them they just kind of like
go after they just bite them or attack
them or you know because like I said
it's a rage virus it's almost kind of
like it it amps up your anger to the
point where you just become like an
animal and you're just like [ __ ]
after this person you're not like hungry
you're not eating them or anything like
that
you're just attacking them and this
movies pretty good I mean especially for
such a low-budget movie it costs five
million pounds yeah but I think I think
really he had to appreciate it in
context of the time you know I mean the
this very there's the feel and the tone
of this movie is very unlike the zombie
movies of its day yeah this actually you
can tell the tone and this one inspired
the tone of The Walking Dead oh yes it's
like all the Walking Dead was calm
ripping off some of these situations
like that rogue soldiers that are trying
to survive on I mean that's a little bit
from Day of the Dead to or daunted yet
David ed that had like the rogue
soldiers and [ __ ] like that but yeah a
lot of the aspects like I said you know
the zombie sub-genre it's not like a
huge sub-genre and as I said Romero did
a lot of this kind of stuff in his Dead
films and also in the crazies so it's
not like they just pulled this out of
their ass that you know what I mean
there's there's other things that
they're referring to and actually the
guy that wrote this screenplay Alex
Garland who was actually a really well
regarded novelist prior to this he
actually and I didn't know this but he
actually wrote the screenplay for Dredd
the remake the good one yeah I like the
original though yeah but I mean that
well the new one was like more suit more
like serious yeah you know I mean where
the other was kind of like yeah yeah
well it the original comic book was a
comedy yeah sure it was you know pretty
kind of zany
but no Stallone's Dredd I liked I liked
them both I like still a little strip
the only thing that you could I really
can really knock Stallone's Dredd for is
that he didn't wear his [ __ ] mask you
only had it a couple slow cuz he had in
this contract he's like I don't want to
like be in a movie and not be able to
see my face on the map yeah
whereas that's one thing I liked about
the remake definitely great one it
looked yet but I mean they both look
good that's what the one thing that I
liked about the the remake one was like
it was a more serious tone into the guy
never took his mask on yeah you know
what I mean I like that
yeah back to the passion of the zombie
genre I'd probably say that this movie
really helps to inspire the walking dead
but I would say the old Walking Dead you
know I'm gonna I'll be the first to
admit that I like The Walking Dead but I
only like maybe the first five seasons
after they after they left terminus it
started to fall apart for me slowly you
know as it went Walking Dead started off
as a really good survival adventure
story with a bunch of horror in there
people were eligible for getting killed
anybody could get killed of that series
but as it went on it kind of mutated
more into kind of soapy yeah
I just didn't really like it and you
knew that certain you knew that the core
characters were gonna get killed anymore
and I just didn't like the writing yeah
they're hiding behind a little bitty
sheet metal you know hiding behind that
this supposed to be posed to be blocking
the assault rifle fire you know it
doesn't work it was a bunch of [ __ ] they
they did wrong and the the the tiger
thing the just seen on certain
characters the way they was shown I just
thought it started to get really corny
yeah and and fear them fear the walking
dead dad never really took off just
didn't like it yeah no I like Salazar
but then they [ __ ] that character up
and it just I just didn't like it I
checked out of him but yeah so um like
I'm saying the guy that wrote this movie
was the same guy that wrote Dredd he was
also the same guy that wrote
annihilation which was a sci-fi movie
that I actually really liked that I
think was kind of underrated I bought
that one as well
um but yeah so he said that he was
actually inspired by he had liked the
eighties zombie movies like all the
Romero movies and stuff that he saw as a
kid and he was kind of into them but
then he kind of forgot about zombies and
still heat heart and still he started
playing the Resident Evil video games
and he kind of got back into zombies
again but he said that the main idea for
28 days later and for the fast zombies
and everything like that not only came
from Resident Evil but also came from
the movie the day of the Triffids which
I thought was kind of interesting he's
out forever but he said that was where
he got the idea of somebody like waking
up and like all the streets being
deserted and stuff like that you know
the day of the Triffids it was an
english movie i think it was black and
white wouldn't I believe it was yeah I
haven't seen it for a long time either
yeah a bunch of alien seeds come down in
meteorites blinds everybody blinds a lot
of the people in England the seeds
hatching these alien plants that eat
people Wow it was great great movie I
know he was yeah love Jerry most people
were blind not everybody sunny certain
people were indoors they were deep
underneath the ground and the light
didn't blind him yeah I don't remember
exactly where the light came from it was
just some kind of radiation but it may
be
were blind it made you a sitting duck
for these damn walking plants yeah they
just kind of crept along they had mouths
on them
alien plans and tentacles and [ __ ] I've
heard that maybe being really creepy I
think I read the book as well John
windhammer wrote it yeah
British soldiers are running around
trying to machine got him and they they
were seemingly indestructible eventually
they figure out how to kill him but I
think John win him also were at the
Midwich cuckoos which was the what was
the movie with all the kids with the
blonde hair that the aliens impregnated
all the women at the same with the name
of them uh-huh you know what I'm talking
about why I can't think of everybody no
yeah yeah oh damn there you go it was
that that was actually based on a book
by John Wayne him although that was
called me cookies but yeah so like I
said des the Triffids and Resident Evil
and the George Romero movies were kind
of a big inspiration to him when he
wrote this now 28 days later like I said
it cost about five million pounds to
make even though I saw I was watching
one review of it earlier where he said
it costs the same as a loaf of Wonder
Bread okay it's a five million loaf of
Wonder Bread okay but yeah it cost five
million pounds to make and it actually
ended up being it did like pretty good
in the UK but when they released it in
the US it was only released on I think
1500 screens and if he does shipped on a
money maybe like forty five million
dollars just on like oh no very limited
release so it actually ended up like
being a really big hit and it was
auction actually even also a big
critical hit like I think it got pretty
much I think was like 90 95 percent
positive reviews so and it kind of went
on to become like I said to become super
super influential and can probably
between that and Resident Evil that's
probably the thing that kind of
kick-started the zombie genre that's
still kind of going on to this day
although it seems like it's kind of
going downhill a little bit in the most
recent I think the new series is gonna
come and take a walk in deads place if
you ask me that's gonna be the stand
yeah it's a rumored to be that there's
gonna be like a Netflix series I think
it's an athlete well again that needs a
serious yeah book it says standing which
it's not a zombie movie but it is an
apocalypse movie yeah yeah it starts off
with a pendent plague that wipes
those still seemed to be seem to be
pretty popular I mean if some of the
later you know I mean I
most of the most recent horror movies
that have done well like either
critically or you know at the box office
they seem to be more like supernatural
horror or more like psychological horror
so I think you're seeing kind of less of
zombie movies maybe people are sick of
them but I definitely feel like a lot of
stuff that's like gone - that's you know
kind of done the horror convention
circuit and the like turning up on
Netflix and stuff there's still like a
lot of post-apocalyptic movies yeah I'd
like to see how this is gonna be done
because the stand had a biblical
apocalyptic themes yeah about the devil
coming back and you know the war of
Armageddon between good survivors and
evil survivors and this it was a badass
book it really was and like I would love
to see like a really good adaptation and
like I said it seems like a good time to
do it because once Stephen King is like
super hot right now
again like they're doing so many remakes
and so many like adaptations of his work
and I feel like there's really a market
out there for it if they could do it
without [ __ ] it up you know so
they're like they do well although like
I said some of the some of the ones they
didn't did on Netflix like it's awesome
like Gerald's game yeah
amazing oh yeah it's good it's on
Netflix they also did that one about the
[ __ ] farmer that killed that that was
more like a over game yeah that was a
great movie yeah
alright so 28 days later had a sequel
called 28 weeks later starring one of my
favorite actors Robert Carlyle and it
was actually for a sequel I actually
liked it I'm not gonna say it was better
than the original but it was almost as
good I liked it a lot I think I saw them
just eight or two I might do a separate
review on that because I really liked
that movie also now Danny Boyle has
repeatedly said that he's kind of
thinking you know oh maybe I'll do like
a third one in the trilogy called 20
months later but he's never got around
to it he's been saying that for like
[ __ ] 12 years and they never got
around to doing it so I don't know if
they're gonna do it at this point cuz
it's been such a long time there's also
been a couple of like um graphic novel
things that were like filling in gaps in
the story one of them was even done by
Steve Niles who very famously did 30
days of night and as I said this movie
was pretty much responsible for I mean
the remake of
Dawn of the Dead that came out I think
two years after this had fast zombies in
it yeah and this actually I'm like I
said I'm kind of ambivalent about
remakes that one kicked ass that was
like a really good it was good but they
shouldn't had the damn fast zombies in
it they should have left him Romero
zombie I'm just saying they did because
if the story was good um and like I said
I mean so many zombie movies came as
Shaun of the Dead came out two years
after this also an amazing flick black
sheep planet terror dead snow which I
[ __ ] love nazi zombies zombies genus
zombie land oh you would like dead since
I haven't seen the sequel but um Dom B
land you would probably like that too
it's like a zombie comedy actually is as
far as British zombie movies go I
probably give it a shot of dead oh no
like I said that's like a horror comedy
yeah I like that this is more a straight
horror movie some of the Romero ones had
a lot of comedy and they're all straight
well they were it is satirical right I
like that tone it's kind of hard to take
the zombie subjects seriously through
the whole movie you not I mean but you
know I guess you can well in this one I
think it's actually more realistic
because it's not reanimated corpses yeah
it's just like people and you could like
it's exaggerated but you could see
something like that happening right
there some kind of virus got released
and it makes everybody crazy and let me
just back up and tell people that we was
called these zombie movies these all
came from what Night of the Living Dead
and yeah they were not zombies they were
Google ghouls
yeah zombies were never mentioned in any
having anything to do at that movie that
was something that the audience kind of
put that yeah and because the zombie
it's not really a dead zombie there's
nothing that's got buried and rock back
you use a voodoo ritual to fake a
person's death they yeah they die and
then you dig them up because they're
catatonic and you make them your slave
and then you have them working in your
sugar cane plan yes this is some [ __ ]
they actually did in Haiti a real zombie
movie probably serpent serpent everybo
and that's like actually one of the few
I mean other than like the old back in
the old days in the 30s and 40s
you know they made I watch with a zombie
white zombie near the head Bela Lugosi
and stuff like that in it
actually did the Haitian zombie angle
and then I feel like they didn't really
do that much anymore serpent the rainbow
is really the only significant example I
can think of that came out the nineties
right I think no sir lady
oh maybe eighties yeah maybe cuz I think
I just just come in yes getting Devers
yeah maybe it was a high school yeah it
was at the time I didn't like it I love
syrup anyway if I see it again maybe I'd
like it but at the time I didn't really
like I I loved surfing the rainbow and
honestly it's um it's on my list to
review I just haven't got around to a
long time yeah and like you said there
were also like a ton of books that came
out in the wake of this Wars II which
was subsequently made into it's not very
good movie Pride and Prejudice and
Zombies warm bodies all this kind of
like so there was like a whole it was
almost like a whole cultural explosion
of like zombies [ __ ] everywhere when
el zombie crazy and a lot of it came
from this movie and pretty and this and
Resident Evil that's pretty much it like
kick-started the whole thing and if you
haven't seen the original Romero's nidal
Living Dead go ahead and unsub well you
got to see that one yeah I just free
it's that's public domain you can see it
for yeah you can see that anywhere
and the way that movie is made that's
still classic to this they made that
poor and to me what makes that movie is
the damn announcer on the television set
in the in the house that's part of the
part yet
there which is their only link to the
outside world and just a cast
yeah they're not all great actors but
they have a really good leading man
what's the name of that character Ben
Ben that's right yeah Ben does a great
job well that's why they put him in the
lead they said he was the best actor we
knew yeah black leading man was like
revolutionary the dead oh man that's
awesome totally by accident was
accidental I know that he was the best
actor we knew so we just named a lead
right and I can it just kind of
inadvertently turned out to be like this
kind of statement
yeah and that's that that whole script
takes on a totally different angle it
doesn't when you have a black leading
man in it oh yeah and that movie count
that was a hard time believing that that
was completely accidental though well
he's the best actor that they had
because I mean George Romero is well
known for putting like a lot of social
commentary
to his movies in particular I think it
just worked yeah this works though it
worked with the story the midden Hance
that story just like you know putting
making written an alien one making
ripley female was totally that was a
fact that I accidentally after and you
know Scott Ridley Scott just went you
know was asked is is Ripley a female and
he goes no oh but yeah yeah it's like it
could be that wouldn't really imagine
like either and then both of those
movies just came away real strong with
you know I mean with with flips like
that yeah you know he kind of flip it
well sometimes I think it's better when
you write a character particularly for a
movie not so much in a book I guess but
you know particularly in a movie if you
just write a character like they could
be either thing and then you know they
can just ask yeah and then like you know
Ben makes it to the very very end and
just looks out the window and gets shot
in the head by rednecks shot by rednecks
and Anna's aunt assam bee hunting team
and it boy it looked a lot like a lynch
mob coming for well yeah that's exactly
the idea like yeah and yeah that's
that's kind of where that happened yeah
now I should add that um I don't
actually have the blu-ray of this of 28
days later now I've heard that there
were three alternate endings because
this movie like if you watch the
theatrical cut at least in the United
States and spoiler alert this has a
fairly positive ending it's like you
know the the nice like teddy bear
character that he gets killed a bunch of
people get killed but Jim survives
Selina survives and the girl survives
like I said forming this kind of like
new family now they have you know the
the zombies or the infected people are
actually starving to death
so they're basically just waiting around
for them to all starve to death and then
they figure everything's gonna be okay
they kind of implied that they thought
that the [ __ ] was happening all around
the world but they find out at the end
that probably it was only Britain so you
know they could you know they could like
move somewhere else later on like
potentially so it has kind of a hopeful
ending of like them like out in this
kind of like a house like out middle of
nowhere and they're you know they see a
plane
coming over and they like have a big
thing like made out of cloth out and the
thing that says hello like and you know
like asking them for help and stuff and
that's where it ends now
they also filmed a couple of other
endings and I haven't seen them but I
heard that pretty much all of the other
endings they filmed two of them and one
of them was just storyboarded all three
of the other endings had Jim dying at
the end I think one of them he was like
being experimented on like a monkey like
at the beginning one of them I think
didn't even have the military people and
it just like happened in a hospital and
it was like some other [ __ ] going on but
yeah I think he died in all three of the
alternate endings and so some people
thought that like some reviews I read a
bit like I said they're pretty much all
positive but some people like oh I think
thought the ending was too happy it's
like it should have been more of like a
downbeat ending because that's probably
what would really happen so I think some
people thought that maybe they should
have had everybody die at the end or
they should have had Jim die at the end
or whatever but I don't know I kind of
liked that little positive thing at the
end and like I said when they made the
sequel where it kind of were the where
the outbreak kind of like spread further
outside of Britain and various other
things you know so I think it fit in
better with that but I can see what
you're saying cuz I'm kind of a fan of
downbeat endings like I kind of like
horror movies it's not that aren't
afraid to bum you out so I can see why
that might piss people off tell you what
these fast zombie movies though they
[ __ ] up Will Smith's I am Legend if
you ask me oh my god don't even get me
started on that movie yep well my name
is Sam why did they even make they
should have never done that it just made
me so angry I think I've paid to see
that in theatres too and then I was like
what the [ __ ] yeah cuz I loved the book
so much and I loved last night on earth
and I loved the Omega Man yeah they
should have made it the Omega Man well
yeah they should have had the albino
psychopathic mutants they could talk the
family yeah that that that movie do you
do you want to see a badass apocalyptic
we did a review on it yeah we did a
Megaman go see Omega we mmmm we haven't
done last man on earth though with the
Vincent Price one and actually that one
is the closest to the book yeah I mean
the Omega man took was it's a great
flick but it took some liberties like it
yeah the same that last minute earth
that wasn't exactly like the book but
it's it's the closest I mean I am Legend
even though it's named the same as the
book
the other adaptations were it was like
it deviated wildly from the source
material and in ways that I think were
ultimately detrimental let's put it that
way yeah weak movie but yeah so if you
like zombie movies and you haven't seen
this one then what the [ __ ] cuz this is
like one of the building blocks of the
modern zombie genre and probably you
need to see it
so go check it out um and I think that
will do it for this movie retrospective
and remember if you like the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
remember if you would like to
financially supports you and go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
that would be much appreciated remember
we do these movie retrospectives that
come out every Friday we also do our
regular episodes come out every Tuesday
and we do 13 o'clock matinee new movies
in the theater that comes out every
Sunday we will see you next time
bye